all right let's talk about another man
then let's talk about sam darnold who is
out for monday night against the
cleveland browns and most likely longer
than that with
mononucleosis it always sounds more
ominous when you say
mononucleosis and look this is going to
take him four to six weeks to recover
from fully he'll have an enlarged spleen
he'll have malaise he'll have weakness
it's going to take some time and the
jets are now going to have to adjust
with trevor simeon playing quarterback a
guy who started 24 games for the broncos
2016 and 2017. are the jets done or can
they weather this storm big cat i oh man
i i mean
for season long
if you're asking me if they're going to
go to the playoffs i would say no but
trevor simeon's not bad he's not good
but he's also not bad and especially sam
darnold you know sam darnold was
supposed to take the the step forward
this year but what sam darnold has been
is trevor seemed simian that far of a
fall off i know sam donald has shown
some flashes but he hasn't been
consistently a great quarterback yet in
his career and i think he will get there
but he hasn't yet this whole thing is
just embarrassing though i mean as a
second year pro to have have mono and
miss and and especially you know guys
missing their second year the growth
that that you exhibit as a second year
quarterback i feel like is really really
important to a career so to miss if it's
six if it's seven i don't know how many
games he's going to end up missing but
this is embarrassing i i'll just say it
i don't know i don't know what how else
to put it i mean you want to be out
there and an injury is one thing but
mono i don't know
don't kiss anyone just don't kiss anyone
for the entire football season well
here's the thing it's highly contagious
not just from kissing and
we we've heard the stories over the
years about staph infections in the
locker room and you know football locker
rooms are just gross nasty disgusting
places and now we have to sit back and
see how many other guys on the jets team
end up with mono and i think that's a
very real concern and i don't know
anything about the incubation period or
when you are
potentially contagious but
i guess you got to worry about guys on
other teams end up getting mono now too
because they're in pretty close quarters
during games so you know this may just
be starting not ending for the new york
jets but uh i i think big cat
it takes a lot of pressure off the jets
on monday night football and it puts a
lot more pressure on the browns look at
last night ultimately the explanation
for last night is the bucks had no
pressure and the panthers had all the
pressure and the panthers did not handle
the pressure well at all how will the
browns handle the extra pressure of
staring owen two in the face
having a win that everyone is handing to
them now that sam darnold is out and i
think it makes monday night's game even
more intriguing because we're going to
learn a lot about the browns a lot more
about them than we're going to learn
about the jets to see if they can
deliver the knockout when they are
expected to do it i agree with you mike
and i also think that taking the the
jets in this game six and a half points
it went from two and a half to six and a
half i don't think trevor simeon is four
points worse than sam darnold sam
darrell might be good in his career but
right now sam donald i think they're
closer than people realize
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports